we all love anime epic battles
heartbreaking tragedy hilarious comedy
and even some of the most passionate
love stories
and even if you're there just for the
badass sword fights
don't we all love to see two long setup
characters
sharing a shy but passionate first kiss
the only thing is there seems to be
absolutely no
kissing in anime
[Music]
okay maybe some but overall i've caught
myself quite often getting frustrated
that two characters that
clearly have fallen for each other and
have had a long romantic storyline
together never seem to end up giving us
the same satisfaction that hollywood and
other western media can't seem to make
enough of
so what's the deal here japan why is
there such
a shortage of proper kissing scenes in
anime
hi my name is o'hara and in this video
we'll be exploring the cultural
differences between japan and the west
when it comes to hissing
and the role it plays in anime so that
you can start to enjoy and appreciate
all that anime romance just a bit more
we humans are absolutely obsessed with
kissing and romance
romance and love are deeply rooted in
the social part of our brains
that was crucial for survival you know
so that we would actually find someone
to make some cute babies with
instead of sitting on trees the entire
days and scratching our balls
and so whenever we kiss or even watch
someone else do it
our brains literally bombard us with
chemicals that trigger these feelings of
pleasure and anticipation
particularly when it comes to a first
kiss even if
it's just on screen and since anime has
become
more and more popular in recent years
it's time to find out
why it's refusing to give us that sweet
sweet dose of dopamine more often
now before we get into this i want to
make clear that when i talk about anime
i look at it more from a mainstream
perspective um
well aware that there are genres like
roman's anime
saiyan anime or anti that have
more kissing scenes in them and as
always
exceptions prove the rule
but even there it's much much less than
you might expect
and even if there is kissing it often
feels
pretty damn awkward
now that being said when i first sat
down to think about the reason for this
kissing shortage
my first thought was it's probably gotta
be the manga cuz right
after all they're the ones who write the
story and you can actually find some
pretty good arguments for this
for example shonen anime in particular
is traditionally aimed at young boys
so maybe kissing is seen to be too girly
but then again shonen has long outgrown
this limitation
with shows like attack on titan full
metal alchemist or shokugeki no soma in
the genre
you can't exactly say that these are all
made for children
actually most of them are probably not
just look at the broad audience a story
like one piece has
across all ages and genders so maybe
it's the age of the characters then
but if they can hunt demons overthrow
governments and commit mass murder
why can't they make out
and so while all of this might play some
role there must be
something else something bigger
something that explains how this
phenomenon stretches so
consistently across an otherwise so
diverse medium
after all we're all well aware just how
powerful and engaging
a well-written romantic plotline where
the fiery first kiss can actually be
our historic literature is full with it
after all
reaching thousands of years back to
homer and his odyssey
and even further and it was right at
this point
that i made a breakthrough the answer i
found
lies not just within anime and manga
but within japanese culture itself
because as it turns out in japan that
has famously been isolated for large
part of its history
kissing has not really been a thing
until
quite recently if you know a bit of
japanese or
have watched enough anime you'll
probably know that the japanese word for
kiss
is actually just the katakana word kisu
so simply copied over from english
now in fact there is a japanese word for
the act itself that dates back to the
ido periods
that looks like this and literally
translates to
mouth sucking ew
actually maybe not so you after all the
catch here however is that this was
simply considered to be a part of
and not a separate concept in itself and
so it
took some more time until kissing
finally got its own specific words
and by some more time i actually mean
the early 20th century
and so the crux of all this is that
kissing in the classically romantic
sense of the west has only reached japan
very very recently and as my japanese
friends confirmed to me when i asked
about it
even though kissing has been widely
normalized today
it still carries a bit of this sexual
connotation and is considered to be a
very intimate thing to do
there actually is a concept in japan
related to this that i think explains
pretty well just how this history
influences the use of kissing in anime
pda now you might or might not have
heard this term before
if you have congratulations you can now
put a cookie emote in the comments
however if you're like me when i first
moved to japan three years ago
and have absolutely no idea what this
means
penguin's doing assets pda stands for
public display of
affection and is actually not just
limited to japan
with this phrase many east asian
countries describe
any sort of public physical contact
between two people
who are attracted to each other this of
course includes kissing
but also supposedly harmless things like
hugging or holding hands
while for westerners it's pretty normal
if admittedly at times a bit annoying to
see a couple go at it in public
or simply cuddle together japanese
people
tend to feel quite uncomfortable about
this stuff it's something that's meant
to be done
in private and that also goes for pda on
tv
and anime is no exception here well
how the hell am i supposed to get any
real romance in these stories then you
might rightfully ask
the answer is simple it's already there
the real secret to understanding romans
and relationships in anime
is to understand how relationships tend
to work in japan
in most western countries a relationship
often starts with a kiss
which is why we love to see it so much
on film then the couple has some time to
get to know each other better
and form an emotional relationship as
well the big
cultural difference here is that
japanese relationships
tend to work the other way around two
people start by spending a lot of time
together building a strong emotional
bonds
and learning what the other person is
all about this emotional tension then
keeps on building
until one formally confesses their
feelings
and hopes for the best that the other
one returns them as well
once you've actually reached kissing
level the relationship
usually has already reached a pretty
serious and also
intimate stage and yes of course there's
also western couples who date for a very
long time before ever kissing
and japanese people who just like to
make out a bar
but in general i think it's quite
undeniable that there is a fundamental
difference in the meaning of a kiss here
in other words
the reason that there seems to be no
kissing in anime
is not because it's meant for kids or
anything but because
kissing plays a very different role in
japanese romance
than it does in the west now thanks to
the internet and globalization in
general
this will surely change in the future
probably but for now if you want to pick
up on the actually surprisingly intense
romance and anime
no matter the genre make sure to look
for these smaller gestures that mean
so much more to japanese people a flirty
conversation or
watching a sunset together actually mean
way more to these characters and a
japanese audience
than you might expect so next time you
watch an anime
pay close attention to these details
instead of waiting for a hot and wet
kiss if you really want that go
watch some hentai anyways
what other cultural differences do you
think play a role in anime
let me know in the comments if you
enjoyed this video a like is much
appreciated and you can click here to
subscribe to the channel
and last but not least here and here for
more of my contents
and you should totally click them or
smash your face into your phone screen
with your nose to
watch them thanks for watching peace